Matthew you asked one of the most
embarrassing and deepest theological
questions at the merger at that the area
where physics and philosophy collide at
the present time we can only teleport
photons particles of light and atoms
like caesium and rubidium that's it for
the present time however in the coming
years we do expect to be able to
teleport molecules maybe water carbon
dioxide after that who knows maybe even
DNA maybe organic molecules now to
teleport a human raises all the ethical
questions that you mentioned because the
original first of all has to be
destroyed in the process of quantum
teleportation so if you get Captain Kirk
zapped him across the room you've now
seen Captain Kirk die you've seen this
atoms fall apart but here's this other
Captain Kirk on the other side of the
room who has the same bad jokes who has
the same character all the personality
quirks as the original Captain Kirk so
the impostor says no I'm real I have the
memories the personality the quarks I am
Captain Kirk well you just saw the
original die and if you believe in a
soul that soul went to heaven or maybe
the other place but that person is dead
so who's this impostor over there that
the imposter have a soul so it raises
the question are we nothing but
information is the soul the essence of
who we are nothing but information well
I'm a physicist we don't know the answer
to that all we're saying is it is
physically possible to teleport an
entire human being across the room or
maybe onto Mars it is physically
possible to do that and it raises a
valid question what happened to the soul
if your original copy died and somebody
out there has all your memories what
does that mean and the answer is we
don't know